[Musique]
de l'opéra qui résonnent dès le matin
entre les murs du conservatoire l'art
lyrique c'est l'une des plus anciennes
disciplines enseignées à orléans
elles mêmes élèves du conservatoire la
cantatrice commune sertillanges a
commencé à enseigner dans les années 80
à l'époque il n'existait que trois
départements de chant lyrique en france
qu'elle avait trois en france il y avait
orléans colmar et perpignan alors
pourquoi ces trois villes
c'est pas choisi au hasard
géographiquement c'est parce qu'en fait
il y avait trois bons professeurs trois
excellents professeurs qui avait fait
plus que leurs preuves avec très bons
résultats et donc voilà c'est pour ça
qu'ils si orléans est né le département
voix voilà en lequel on a vu débarquer
monsieur roberto alagna qui a fait un
nombre sont ici à orléans
et c'est ici sur la scène de la salle de
concert du conservatoire que le ténor a
chanté au tout début de sa carrière un
lieu stimulant pour aurore
pour faire tout ce qui est venu ans
piano forte et rien de dossier des
halles que cette salle parce que le
professeur se met au fond il a vraiment
tout la récup la répercussion du son et
donc du coup il peut vraiment nous le
dire tout de suite si c'est trop fort
s'il faut attaquer plus doucement c'est
vraiment la répercussion du sens à rama
yade elle dans cette salle aurore
composent le groupe d'une vingtaine
d'adultes qui suivent des cours d'art
lyrique
voilà je suis sûr que tu peux le faire
sans respirer elle est sortie diplômée
du conservatoire mais continue à
perfectionner son champ
voilà c'est mon sonas extraits de la
traviata c'est le libya mots quand on
connaît tous quand même assez connu et
je le chante parce que je travaille dès
maintenant dans une école de musique en
tant que chef de choeur et comme le
jeune cours j'en profite pour
perfectionner l'italien parce que c'est
difficile pour moi que l'allemand et
c'est une version sans ténor oui c'est
une version santé normalement c'est un
duo entre manor et us open avec un petit
cuir derrière mais là je fais tout est
rose
dis moi le premier mot analystes voilà
travailler sa voix chaque jour pour être
en capacité d'enseigner de se produire
sur scène c'est justement ce qui attend
aurore que l'on entendra bientôt en solo
au sein du choeur de la comédie musicale
my fair lady
[Musique]
on